Paul and Ringo
Prince Harry visited London's iconic
Abbey Road Studios on Friday to meet up
with musician John Bongiovi the 35 year
old Duke of Sussex and the 57 year old
musician are teaming up for Harry's
beloved Invictus games the event he
founded for wounded injured and sick
military veterans to compete in sports
based on their abilities to mark the
occasion the Invictus games choir joined
Bon Jovi to re-record his song unbroken
I was very aware of what he's done the
good works he'd done in the Invictus
games and I said I've got an idea
because I think that the soldiers
knowing that they had a choir could sing
this song tell their story it would
promote the games
[Music]
the pair also posed for photos with
members of the Invictus choir in the
iconic crosswalk outside of the studio
The Beatles recorded their many iconic
hits before the studio sesh John joked
about Harry dropping his royal title I
was wondering what do I call him now and
I've come up with the idea he's going to
be known as the artist formerly known as
Prince Harry and Megan announced their
plans to step down as senior members of
the royal family in January and will
split their time between Canada and the
UK going forward but when it comes to
security
turns out Megan and Harry it will soon
be paying for their own in a statement
to Reuters the Canadian office of the
Minister of Public Safety said that once
Megan and Harry are no longer senior
members of the royal family the country
it will not cover the cost of their
security which the outlet reports is
estimated to cost millions of dollars
and according to the statement the Royal
Canadian Mounted Police have been
assisting London's Metropolitan Police
with security for the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex intermittently since November
the change is happening very soon the
couple is scheduled to officially step
down as senior members of the royal
family on March 31st it doesn't change
who I am or how committed I am
but I hope that helps you understand
what did it come to that I would step my
family back from all I have ever known
to stick is to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
[Music]